hi i'm alvin and today i'm gonna be
showing you guys how to make my crispy
chicken thighs with caprese bread salad
so you guys might know me i make a lot
of videos where i take on challenging
recipes and those are kind of fun but
when i cook for myself at home i like
food with a lot of flavor and not a lot
of effort and one of my favorite ways to
add that savory taste without a lot of
effort is msg
so i'm making a recipe with msg today
it's an ingredient that's been unfairly
villainized for decades but is actually
totally safe and delicious i like to
describe it as that kind of extra
something special that you can add to
your food and it makes it taste really
good you're not really quite sure why it
tastes that good it's really great on
meats like chicken as well as vegetables
which don't usually offer a savory taste
on their own
for my crispy chicken thighs i'm using
half a teaspoon of msg and half a
teaspoon of salt you can reduce the
sodium intake without sacrificing the
flavor when you think of msg usually you
think of asian food but i think it can
really apply to a bunch of different
cuisines
at home i don't just cook asian food but
i find myself putting msg in like
everything because it just tastes really
good
well a lot of people might not know is
that it's actually naturally in a lot of
the foods we eat like tomatoes parmesan
mushrooms seaweed and a bunch of other
stuff it's a really accessible
ingredient you can find msg in regular
grocery stores not just in asian markets
or online msg is also available as
accent
i think when it comes to cooking at home
the goal is to be simple quick but still
have lots of flavor and i think this
recipe is really good because none of
the ingredients are super complicated
but you have stuff like the msg that
kind of brings the natural flavor out of
everything you don't have to do too much
with it and it's going to taste really
good that's also really why i like to
use msg and home cooking because it just
adds a lot of flavor and i don't even
have to do much
well there you have it this is my crispy
chicken thighs with caprese bread salad
it's really easy and i encourage you
guys to explore how you can use msg in
your home cooking and i'm gonna go eat
now
oh yes